soldados de azerbaiyán intentando cruzar
la frontera con Armenia es lo que
mostrarían estas imágenes según el
Ministerio de defensa armenio los
combates entre ambos países se
reanudaron en la noche del lunes a este
martes y ambos países se acusan de
romper La tregua acordada en 2020 una
agresión denuncia a ereván una respuesta
afirmaba q por la noche los grupos de
Sabotaje de las fuerzas armadas armenias
utilizando el terreno montañoso de la
zona y Los barrancos existentes minaron
los territorios y las carreteras de
suministro entre las posiciones de las
unidades del ejército de azerbaiyán en
diferentes direcciones
azerbaiyán Está tratando de afirmar que
estas acciones se produjeron como
respuesta a algún tipo de provocación de
la parte Armenia pero definitivamente
podemos afirmar que esta información es
absolutamente falsa y no tiene nada que
ver con la realidad
el gobierno de azerbaiyán no declaró el
número de pérdidas entre sus filas
mientras que Armenia asegura que decenas
de sus soldados perdieron la vida los
ataques fueron dirigidos alrededor de la
zona fronteriza del nagorno caravag una
ex provincia soviética ubicada en una
región montañosa en disputa poblada de
mayoría Armenia que quiere salir de las
fronteras de azerbaiyán
en 2020 ambos estados se enfrentaron por
el control regional en la Segunda Guerra
del nagorno caravag ereván perdió y
cedió territorio a bakú y más de 6.500
personas murieron como consecuencia de
los combates hasta ahora Armenia contó
con la ayuda de Rusia que estableció una
misión de paz en la zona desde entonces
ha habido varios choques a lo largo de
la frontera común sin embargo los de
este martes fueron los más intensos pero
en estos momentos la invasión de Ucrania
es prioritaria para el kremlin y tanto
Rusia como la Unión Europea tienen
intereses que pasan por azerbaiyán